[Música]
cinco años más del presidente de Cuba
Miguel díaz-canel la asamblea nacional
lo eligió por una votación casi unánime
para su segundo periodo a la ceremonia
asistió el líder Raúl Castro
en ningún grado de las escuelas de
Florida en Estados Unidos se podrá
hablar de orientación sexual e identidad
de género el departamento de Educación
amplió la ley conocida como no digas gay
para aplicarla Más allá de la primaria
y el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro propone cambiar la carta
democrática en su discurso ante la oea
el izquierdista defendió al expresidente
peruano Pedro castillo y abogó para que
Venezuela regrese al sistema
interamericano
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle iniciamos en Cuba donde la
asamblea nacional ratificó al presidente
Miguel Díaz canel para un segundo
periodo presidencial durante su primer
gobierno la economía cayó un 11% en 2020
a causa de la pandemia y ahora el
reelecto presidente deberá seguir
enfrentando la difícil situación
económica veamos el informe de Rafael
Pérez
no hubo sorpresas pero casi unanimidad
con más del 97% de los votos Miguel Díaz
canel accedió a un segundo mandato en
Cuba declaro
Miguel Díaz Bermúdez presidente de la
república de Cuba serán otros cinco años
con el timonel de los destinos de la
isla y un último período según la
constitución en lo que pueda representar
el último acto de formación de gobierno
en presencia de los fundadores políticos
del país Díaz canel tuvo palabras para
los que lo adversan Pero no puedo dejar
de
actitudes la de los que critican del
modo más efectivo luchando haciendo
mostrando o creando soluciones y la de
aquellos que solo ven los errores y las
culpas de otros a su vez el jefe de
estado propuso a Manuel marrero para
desempeñarse como Primer Ministro
mandato ratificado por la asamblea la
máxima dirección del país se mantiene
intacta solo el consejo de ministros
sufrió leves cambios seis nuevos
integrantes fueron propuestos de la
generación de guerrilleros de Fidel solo
uno se mantiene Ramiro Valdez Menéndez
próximo a cumplir 91 años quien se
desempeña como viceprimer ministro
varios son los retos que enfrenta el
mandatario para sus próximos cinco años
entre ellos tomar un rumbo propio y las
renovaciones que ello implica con la
inercia de este primer mandato en que lo
que primo es somos continuidad y la
rigidez ideológica frente al pragmatismo
económico o si introducirá los cambios
que todo el mundo Espera que se produzca
Cuba viene golpeada por las
consecuencias de la pandemia un
endurecimiento de las sanciones de
Estados Unidos en las que Joe biden no
ha dado marcha atrás y dificultades
internas como escasez de combustible y
un aumento en el costo de vida que ha
generado protestas inéditas retos para
los que el quinto presidente de Cuba
desde 1959 tendrá una segunda
oportunidad para encontrar soluciones
la ley conocida como no digas gay
aplicará para todos los grados escolares
en Florida Estados Unidos así el
departamento de Educación extendió la
Norma que inicialmente aplicó solo en
primaria y en las aulas no se podrá
hablar de identidad de género ni de
orientación sexual lluís Muñoz nos
cuenta
es una de las muchas guerras culturales
de Estados Unidos la de la orientación
sexual y cómo abordarla en el sistema
educativo Florida expandió su ley
conocida como no digas gay los maestros
ahora no podrán enseñar sobre el tema y
sobre identidad de género en ningún
grado escolar las únicas excepciones
serán cuando le exijan los estándares
estatales o como parte de la instrucción
de salud reproductiva además la cámara
prohibió la atención de brindar atención
médica para transiciones de género en
menores el uso del baño que no sea el
del sexo asignado al nacer y la
presencia de niños en espectáculos de
Drag Queen el gobernador ronde santis
dice luchar contra el progresismo y las
diversidades conocidas como Wow
esta agenda izquierdista la ideología
Walk es una amenaza Para nuestras
libertades nuestros resultados finales
no nos rendimos a la mafia woke Florida
es donde lo Walk va a morir
a medida que de santis legisla también
llegan protestas en este caso de los
estudiantes de educación superior que
serían los próximos afectados por las
reformas ultraconservadoras los
republicanos quieren eliminar la teoría
crítica de la raza y la teoría queer de
las universidades
estamos muy preocupados con toda la
censura y todo el borrado que están
tratando de hacer con El currículo
creemos que las clases son un espacio
para el pensamiento libre crítico donde
tener conversaciones difíciles
recientemente de santis ha promulgado
una ley que prohíbe el aborto después de
las seis semanas y está en una guerra
abierta con Disney la compañía se opuso
la ley no digas gay y ron de santis
quiere ahora limitar la supervisión de
Disney de sus parques temáticos medidas
con las que busca avalarse entre los
conservadores de Cara a las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano
[Aplausos]
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
habló este miércoles del Consejo
permanente de la Organización de Estados
Americanos la oea y allí propuso cambiar
la carta democrática Interamericana el
izquierdista también mencionó al
destituido presidente de Perú Pedro
castillo y abogó para que le quiten
progresivamente las sanciones a
Venezuela y el país vuelva al sistema
interamericano es uno de los temas que
discutirá con el presidente de
estadounidense Joe biden escuchemos
la carta democrática que solo una
sentencia judicial de juez penal
quita derechos políticos
Entonces porque le están quitando
derechos políticos al pueblo
si no hay sentencia judicial no lo
estamos viendo ahora en Perú no podría
suceder en Colombia o en otro país
cualquiera de los que aquí presentes no
estamos vulnerando el pacto democrático
de las Américas en lugar de ir hacia una
carta más amplia de derecho de
profundización de la Democracia hacia un
proyecto democrático que haga de América
Latina el gran faro Mundial de la razón
y de la Libertad
continúa su gira por América Latina
después de visitar Brasil y Venezuela el
miércoles llegó a Nicaragua donde lo
recibió el presidente Daniel Ortega tras
el encuentro con el mandatario labrov
destacó los estrechos vínculos entre
Rusia y Nicaragua se espera que el
ministro vuele a Cuba este jueves para
cerrar así su viaje oficial por algunos
de los países con gobiernos de izquierda
en la región
el gobierno de El Salvador prohibió
publicar el más reciente informe del
fondo monetario internacional sobre la
economía del país en un informe de
preliminar el organismo elogió el
crecimiento Sólido del pib y de las
remesas pero insistió en que existe un
riesgo de inestabilidad financiera por
el uso del bitcoin como moneda de curso
legal al gobierno de nayib bukele no le
gustó esto y tampoco la petición de
mayor transparencia sobre las
transacciones gubernamentales con esta
criptomoneda
los incendios forestales amenazan las
principales zonas de protección de la
capital de Honduras Tegucigalpa las
autoridades denuncian que algunos son
provocados por pirómanos y otros por la
ola de calor nuestra corresponsal Kenia
Torres estuvo en una de las zonas cero Y
esta es la historia
Sandra canales lidera el equipo de
protección forestal que realiza labores
de combate contra los incendios
forestales que están Arrasando los
terrenos en zonas protegidas de
Tegucigalpa este incendio pues está
dentro de un área protegida si bien es
cierto Está en un área de
amortiguamiento como se lo menciona pero
es parte de un área protegida es un área
de Gran importancia ecológica verdad
para la ciudad capital
ya que son zonas de recarga Además del
interés ecológico por la flora y fauna
unos 100 miembros del equipo
especializado del ejército atacan el
incendio desde otro flanco según
investigaciones los quirómanos y el
ardiente verano son las principales
causas de las quemas este momento se
está haciendo una ronda de prevención
para posteriormente realizar el
contrafuego y poder liquidar este
incendio que de gran magnitud pese a las
campañas de prevención según las
autoridades en lo que va del 2023
823 incendios forestales han consumido
unas 50.000 hectáreas de bosque como
trabajando desde el mes de noviembre
gracias al aumento del presupuesto
operativo del icf para la parte de
protección forestal en actividades de
prevención forestal como quemas
prescritas para reducir El combustible
evitar la propagación del fuego eh
rondas cortafuegos cinturones negro
capacitación de personal el devastador
panorama se registra en medio de una ola
de calor y ha provocado que la capital
esté envuelta en una densa capa de humo
los expertos esperan que la temporada de
incendios llegue a su fin con el inicio
de las lluvias el próximo mes de mayo
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]